main lourde et mesures plus sévères contre
les dépravés et les dégénérés qui
Ils détruisent toujours des vies innocentes
famille et 220 enfants et jeunes
nous envisageons d'appliquer la castration
chimie
comme l'une des mesures drastiques contre
violeurs mineurs
adolescents et femmes cette proposition
sera officialisé dans les prochains jours et
Nous espérons le soutien du Congrès et que
ne tourne pas le dos à un cri populaire
réalisation
de l'Èbre
rien
[Musique]
Assez de tant d'abus contre
nos enfants dont nous voulons prendre soin
nos enfants veulent justice pour
nos enfants meurent peine de mort
devrait provenir de l'expression que
indiquant
[Musique]